so today we're going to be making a
secure rest api now this concept here
can be applied to pretty much any api
type but i do want to add that we have
quite a lot of code to go over and i
want the video to be as short as
possible so i will go over the code fast
i have tried to put as many comments as
possible so you can go ahead and read it
all the code as usual will be in the
description and i do also expect you
guys to know express since i'm not going
to be explaining the basics of express
but here we go we have an express app we
import the dependencies we set up a
basic express server and we make sure
that it can take json this here is not
necessary for this example but this code
is actually taken from my own website so
that's why this is here but essentially
it's just so you can send more data and
for a production app this is maybe
useful but then we set up our routes we
have an authenticate route and we have a
messages route now you can have as many
routes as you want but for this example
i just have one which is messages and
then i have the route that will
authenticate us then we set up the
routes here and i essentially i map them
to a url
and then we just start the server let's
go ahead and take a look at the
authenticate route
now we import json web tokens which i
have made a video on in the past and we
use bcrypt as well to uh encrypt our
passwords then we set up the router here
and then on post request we make all the
sign-in information so the way this
works is that you put in an email and a
password and that will give you a token
which will be valid for 15 minutes which
you can use to use the api and there's
three different usual levels so there's
an admin there's a viewer and an editor
but you can really change them to
whatever you want for your api this data
would come normally from a database but
because i didn't want this video to be
too long i've just made it an array now
you can see here we have an email we
have a password which i will show you
how to generate and then we have the
roles over here now the way it works is
that we have an admin and an editor and
a viewer so
it's it's a bit um the way this works
you could change this but essentially
just because you're an admin doesn't
mean you can view so you would need to
have all three
to be a full admin that can both view
edit and be an admin so you know you
could see this as individual um
rules and it's sort of a bad naming
convention but yeah
um here we find the user by the email
that we put in
and down here we compare
the password using bcrypt
we will then create a token with a user
id and the row and this is our private
key this of course you would get from
environment variable and this you of
course want it to be more secure then we
expire in 15 minutes the reason why we
do this is let's say that you gave a
token with all these permissions here
and then you went into the database and
changed so it was only a viewer and not
an admin and an editor and a viewer
then that token there you gave before
would be valid for pretty much all time
and you would not be able to change that
so this way it just makes sure that the
token is only valid for 15 minutes and
after 15 minutes they will need to ask
for new token where you could go ahead
and change the roles or the password or
the email
and then we just go ahead and send this
i do want to add that i do this here the
reason why i do this is it's just
something that i really like for
front-end application that there's just
okay and if it's not okay it's false if
it's okay it's true i have that on all
my api endpoints the messages route i'm
also going to go pretty quick over
but we import the authenticate route we
import our free roles here then we have
a temporary list which would normally be
the database then we have a get request
which will get that and you have to be a
viewer you can see the way we pass this
in is that we pass an authenticate which
will make sure to authenticate the user
and if the user is valid then it will
get one of those user types here which
the viewer editor or admin will go ahead
and check and if any of these fail we
will not get to this endpoint here but
get essentially shows the messages
post essentially adds one again this
would normally be a database but in this
case it's just a local array i've not
implemented the put i'm sure you guys
can figure out how to do that and for
the delete we just delete it
now let's take a look at our middlewares
this is our authenticate middleware and
all i do is i export this as a
middleware and then i go ahead and check
this this is the header so in the header
and i will show you this guys later in
postman this is the header you will need
to set the token to so that's the header
name and then we'll go ahead and check
that token and we just do some
verification here verify that it was us
that issued that token and then we'll go
ahead and check if it is expired and if
it isn't then we'll go ahead and proceed
and this is the way the different roles
work this is admin the editor and the
viewer this is here where you could say
if it is an admin it would also be an
editor and a viewer or you could pretty
much do anything in here you could also
rename them or you can add more roles
but that's essentially the way the roles
work they're very simple now if we go
back to our authenticate and we have our
user here
and the way i got this password here is
by this script here so it's pretty
simple all this is is the password in my
case my password is one two three so you
put this in and you run this file just
stand alone it doesn't have anything to
do with the application and that will go
ahead and generate the password that is
valid but guys that was pretty much the
entire application let's take a look at
how it works
all right guys so this is postman now
postman is a way for testing your api
you don't need this but it's very useful
if you want to test your api so you can
see here we send a post request and what
we need to provide is our email and our
password so we provide the same email as
we had in
here and the password and then we go
ahead and hit send and that will give us
a token which is valid for 15 minutes
okay so we can then go ahead and take
this into the messages and we can make a
get request with this token and then we
can get all of the messages if we don't
provide this well we'll get an access
denied token not provided
there you go so this is what you would
have to implement in your front end code
sending this token here and refreshing
it every 15 minutes we can also of
course add messages so the way we do
that is that we make a post request
instead and then we make sure to define
the body if you want to know how to
define the body in postman all you do is
you set it to raw and then you make sure
to change this over here but then we can
go ahead and send the name and the
content oh we can actually see i did not
refresh the token so this is what
happens when you use an old token so all
you will have to do is just go over here
and change that token and there you go
now it works
and here there you go we can then see
the git data now guys i know that i went
over the code pretty fast but i like
doing short videos you guys like
watching short videos so that is really
the way it has to be if i um have to
show you these bigger projects so if you
guys want a part two of this comment
that down below and comment what you
want to see do you guys want to see me
implementing user validation or do you
guys want me to implement a database so
we can actually store these users here
or do you guys not want a part two of
this video at all if you have the video
ideas put them down below i can't
guarantee that i will do them but i will
add them to my list and i know i've not
been doing too many videos lately and
this pop-up it's just really annoying
guys i'm not going to pay for avg vpn
okay go away i've really been seeing the
channel lately getting a lot of new
subscribers and a lot of new views and i
just thought that was so exciting so
that's really the reason why i'm making
this video i want to make a new video
for all the new subscribers which i got
over the last month which was quite a
lot we are almost guys at 900
subscribers and then we're really only
100 away from the 1000 mark which would
really mean a lot to me if we could hit
that 1000 mark i know it's possible and
i know you guys can make it possible and
i really really want it to be 1000 now
the reason why is not so much for the
advertisement because i will have to
have 4000 watch hours anyways which i
don't have but these videos i'm making
them for fun and i want as many people
as possible to see them so if you guys
know anybody or that's interested in
development then please go ahead and
share the video it really really mean
the world to me and yeah guys that was
everything for today and hopefully you
enjoyed this video and hopefully see you
in the next one